after dropping into the frigid waters
off Antarctica researchers from
Greenpeace saw this a part of the
Antarctic ocean floor never before seen
by humans what they saw was an ecosystem
so dense with life they are now trying
to convince an International Commission
to grant the area special protection
over 1 million square miles would be
included in the proposed sanctuary
making it the largest protected area on
earth climate changes warming the
Antarctic Peninsula faster than anywhere
else on earth and this is a real problem
for us because 90% of the world's
freshwater is trapped here and snow and
ice it's also a problem for Penguins and
whales and other marine life here
because melting sea ice means less
habitat for krill which feed on plankton
that lives on the other surface of the
ice the 3-month
expedition was originally set to carry
out scientific research to support the
need for the sanctuary but the crew has
made an exception to allow one more
mission stranger things star David
Harbour accepted a Twitter challenge to
reach 200,000 retweets in order to join
Greenpeace 'as Antarctic expedition
David Harbor and happy about them and
people who have some real influence are
incredibly helpful in that will be able
to reach millions of people about the
importance of protecting the Antarctic
Ocean we live on a beautiful planet John
we are lucky we sure do I would love to
go there